how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to cosmic wonder where we
talk about all things relating to the
MCU as if there wasn't enough excitement
around the MC right now around phase
four and phase five the new characters
that are coming to the MCU the x-men and
the Fantastic Four today we have an
amazingly crazy rumor stating that
Wolverine is going to be coming to the
MCU in Captain Marvel 2 and is going to
be played by Henry Cavill
the former Superman for DC now if you're
like me this news is probably a
whirlwind of emotions and I just want to
state that right now this is in no way
confirmed it's just a rumor but I am
going to be going over all of the
different reports that state Henry
Cavill is going to be in Captain Marvel
2 as Wolverine and we'll go over sources
as well and try to figure out the
validity of this rumor because this is
just massive news Wolverine and the MCU
is something that everybody really wants
however is very tricky to do since Hugh
Jackman was such an amazing Wolverine
it's hard to imagine anybody taking his
place especially since he played the
character for over 17 years when you
think of Wolverine you think Hugh
Jackman but let's break down this rumor
if you are new be sure to subscribe and
hit the notification bell to stay up to
date on the MCU and I'm also giving away
an Xbox one or ps4 winner chooses when I
hit five hundred and fifty eight
thousand subscribers so I've seen many
different YouTube channels promoting
this and I've chased it back to a couple
of different articles and one is from
the digital weekly and the article
starts off with Henry Cavill to play
Wolverine and brie Larson's Captain
Marvel to break down of the viral rumor
and it says sources have claimed that
Henry Cavill is in talks to play the
role of Wolverine in brie Larson's
Captain Marvel - it is rumored that
henry cavill will be introduced as
wolverine in the MCU marvel since
acquiring Fox Studios was looking for a
way to add some x-men characters into
the MCU Marvel acquired all rights to
x-men after buying Fox chopping them a
bit to introduce them in the MCU so this
part we pretty much know there actually
was a rumor a couple of months ago that
Henry Cavill was in talks with Marvel
Studios to play Wolverine it was just a
rumor
the time but now it's resurfaced with
people saying that they have sources
telling them that it is in fact
happening and as far as Marvel chopping
the x-men up as far as we're concerned
this is for the most part happening
which isn't really that big of a
surprise because we know that Marvel is
not going to do what Fox did with the
x-men they're not going to have x-men
films the same way Fox did instead what
appears to be Marvel's plan is to
introduce them in other MCU films before
making an x-men movie but the article
goes on to say recently some Marvel
sources have revealed that Henry Cavill
was approached to play the role of an
unknown character in one of the Marvel
movies currently in production this
right here so far extremely possible
Kevin Feige has already admitted that he
talks to many many different actors
about almost every MCU film that they
make he stated this before about Jake
Gyllenhaal and about Keanu Reeves
he said that they met with Jake
Gyllenhaal about a handful of movies
before finally settling on the role
Mysterio he then confirmed that they'd
do the same for Keanu Reeves he said
that they've met with Keanu pretty much
about every movie that they've made
unfortunately they haven't cast him yet
because there just hasn't been that
perfect role for him to play so it's
entirely possible and plausible that
they have been talking with Henry Cavill
about a role in the MCU the article goes
on to say looking at the sources and
credits of the current rumors and
procedures at the MCU everyone begins to
think that Henry Cavill can be
introduced as the new Wolverine and
Captain Marvel two of brie Larson they
then go on to say that Marvel Studios is
looking for the perfect opportunity to
introduce Wolverine into the MCU and of
course this is true Wolverine is one of
the most popular x-men so you know
Marvel and the fans are dying to see him
in the MCU it just has to work because
if they just randomly throw them in
there it's not gonna work and fans
aren't going to be pleased and this is
where the report of Wolverine being
introduced and Captain Marvel 2 comes in
this article states that since Marvel is
not going to do what Fox did with
Wolverine and with the x-men films it's
appropriate for them to go back to their
comic roots and start the story of
Wolverine where it suits him in the
comics Captain Marvel and Wolverine met
before they were both their iconic
characters and very recently Marvel has
announced a new comic series that will
bring together Captain
Marvel and Wolverine with friendship
roots from the past and references to
Comics Marvel may be planning on
presenting Wolverine to the MCU through
Captain Marvel 2 now this article says
sources a lot and it's only source is
all everything entertainment and they
have an article released yesterday that
says Henry Cavill to play Wolverine in
the MCU now for the most part this
article states everything that the
previous article stated stating that
sources say that henry cavill is and
talks with Marvel Studios to play a
certain character and it's expected to
be Wolverine and what's really
interesting is that this does in fact
line up with other reports that we've
gotten about Captain Marvel - and a
mutant showing up now according to Mikey
Sutton this mutant that is going to be
appearing in Captain Marvel 2 is rogue
and rogue showing up in Captain Marvel 2
actually does connect Wolverine with
Captain Marvel in a very strange way you
see Wolverine and Captain Marvel in the
comics actually were quite good friends
as you most likely know Captain Marvel
and Logan were both in the military
Carol Danvers was in the Air Force and
Logan was in the Canadian Army and then
recruited by the CIA Carol working for
the air force intelligent got a chance
to work on many different top secret
missions with everyone from Nick Fury to
Logan this was before Logan was
experimented on with the Weapon X
project and before Carol Danvers got her
creep hours Logan and Carol spent a lot
of time together during their time in
the Special Forces but eventually would
part ways Carol would go on to become
Captain Marvel and Logan would go on to
become Wolverine despite being a part
their relationship remained very strong
and when times got tough they would
often seek each other's help and this is
where the MCU story of Wolverine Captain
Marvel and rogue could come into play
after being away from Earth Captain
Marvel returns but unfortunately when
she gets to earth her powers and her
memory are absorbed and stolen from her
by the mutant rogue now Captain Marvel
and rogue have a very long history
together as well and rogue is a very
frequent villain of Captain Marvel and
she's very powerful in the fact that she
can take in harness captain Marvel's
powers after getting her memory erased
and power stolen the x-men recognize her
they rescue her and when she comes
across Logan she decides to stay with
the x-men now what's important to note
is that at
same time both Logan and Carol Danvers
were a part of the Avengers then many
years down the road they would both be a
part of the New Avengers and we know
that the New Avengers are being planned
for their introduction to the MCU and we
know that Captain Marvel is said to be a
leader of the New Avengers team once
it's developed and the plan for the
x-men to be introduced in the MCU is
going to be over time gradually but
Kevin Feige has already stated that the
x-men and the Fantastic Four will be a
part of the New Avengers team in a
recent interview after San Diego
comic-con Kevin Feige was asked about
the chances of the x-men and Deadpool
making appearances and future of vengers
films in this interview he was asked is
there any reason to believe that the
x-men and Deadpool would not be
integrated with the Avengers and these
characters as well at some point in
which he responded no no reason to
believe that confirming that the x-men
and Deadpool will eventually join up
with the Avengers so we know that
Captain Marvel is going to go on to be a
major player in the New Avengers team
and we know that the x-men will
eventually join the New Avengers as well
and of course not to mention the
Fantastic Four and in order for them to
be a part of the New Avengers team when
they come they have to be introduced in
the MCU first of course so right now as
it stands Mikey Sutton has reported that
rogue is going to be in Captain Marvel -
and there are rumors suggesting that
Henry Cavill is going to play Wolverine
and Captain Marvel - now unfortunately
although there is a precedence for
Wolverine and Captain Marvel to appear
together and even rogue both of these
articles claiming that Henry Cavill
could be in Captain Marvel - don't
really list any sources they simply say
sources at Marvel or Marvel sources so
this can't be confirmed and is simply a
rumor right now which is unfortunate but
it does beg the question would Henry
Cavill be a good Wolverine in the MCU
Hugh Jackman was pretty much a perfect
Wolverine however one complaint that
fans had was that he was too tall
according to the comics Wolverine is 5
foot 3 inches Hugh Jackman was 6 foot 2
so almost a full foot taller than
Wolverine should be and Henry Cavill is
6 foot 1 but a few Jackman made it work
actors certainly can make it work as
well right now Henry Cavill is 36 years
old turning 37 on May 5th so he
definitely is the age he could
definitely play Wolverine for another 15
to 20 years and of course he does have
experience playing a super hero of
course he played Superman and right now
he's a very sought after actor starring
in the last mission impossible and of
course starring in the Netflix series
The Witcher and again it is very
possible that he's met with Marvel
Studios to play a character however it's
not confirmed that that character is
Wolverine if it's anything similar to
the other actors that have met with
Marvel Studios he's most likely meeting
with them about eight a lot of potential
roles but hopefully he is meeting with
Marvel Studios about possibly playing
Wolverine we'll have to wait until we
get some more official reports right now
unfortunately this is just a rumor but I
do want to know do you think Henry
Cavill would make a good Wolverine and
if you don't who do you think would make
a perfect one list who you would like to
play Wolverine in the comments down
below and tell me why don't forget to
leave a like on the video if you loved
the MCU and subscribe so you can stay up
to date with it and I'm still giving
away an Xbox one or ps4 winner gets to
choose and I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
don't forget to join my discord and
follow me on Twitter and Instagram and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof